the endangered lowland gorillas are a
species of gray tape they inhabit the
rainforests in the north of the Republic
of Congo the majority live outside the
national parks in forests that are open
to logging the logging operations pose a
threat to the gorillas habitat
it's only a question of time before some
tracks of forests disappear completely
environmentalists are looking for
alternatives for a sustainable forestry
that ensures the survival of the
gorillas habitat and it is hoped of the
gorillas themselves anh tuan couturier
studied tropical ecology in Paris he's
now working to ensure that logging in
the Republic of Congo is conducted
according to scientific criteria he has
divided a particular forest tracked into
30 zones only one is to be open to
logging in any given year couturier does
an inventory of the rainforest before
the loggers arrive he and his 11 staff
members spend weeks combing the forest
counting trees and taking notes they
make their way through underbrush and
rugged terrain recording every large
tree then they enter the data from the
forest into a computer data bank this
will serve as the basis for more
detailed studies later on
not only do they count trees they take a
census of the gorillas as well you see
was Evie the eyes here we have the
results of the gorilla census the darker
the zone the greater the number of
gorillas living there for that will NOS
Leroy ec paisan here for example there's
a very high density of gorillas in a
zone that we've had protected as a
reserve Zonis you won his own song or
sell this one over one quarter of the
forest is off limits to the loggers but
open for the gorillas to forage in peace
around thirty six thousand live in the
area nearly one-third of all gorillas in
central Africa and more than anywhere
else
in the other zones only one tree may be
felled per year in an area the size of
two soccer pitches
the vegetation swiftly reclaims any
space left open and will soon attract
guerrillas who liked a munch on the
tender shoots of young plants around the
tree stump mescal said the police
officer by our observations we know that
not only gorillas but Buffalo and
elephants move in soon after trees are
cut it's only a matter of days or weeks
so there are just as many gorillas
before and after the Logging's taken
place and there are just as many here as
in the National Park and go good luck
nishimura these ecologists say that
establishing sustainable forestry in
Africa's rainforests is essential to
make sure the lowland gorillas and other
species have a future in the wild